let's see what happens with carhartt bbc
reports carhartt facing calls for
boycott over vaccine mandates the
outcry comes amid a fierce debate over
the u.s coveted 19 jabs this month
scotus said the government could not
force large employers to make covet 19
vaccination or weekly testing mandatory
companies including the coffee chain
starbucks have since reversed their
plans but in a recent memo to staff
carhartt leaders said the supreme court
decision had not changed the company
requirements now this is resulting in
many people calling for a boycott i'll
tell you first the funniest thing i love
it i responded to this by saying how
about this if you work for a carhartt
and you don't want to get vaccinated
quit
my my view on this is like i'm not a
communist i'm not going to demand a
private business
be forced to employ me or or you know if
i don't want to work there i won't but
for some reason the left ragged on me
for it
oh and the best part was on reddit they
were like uh but he's right though like
he's he's telling him to quit what's
what's wrong with that yeah i don't
think there's any actual principle for
the most part behind what carhartt is
doing and behind what people uh the the
establishment left and and pro-mandate
people believe it's all tribal if they
can make fun of someone quote unquote on
the right they'll do it even if they
they should be agreeing with it now as
for car the company
what do you think you think they're
going to lose money on this deal listen
i know carhartt because ninety percent
of my wardrobe is carhartt right now
we're in car now oh no absolutely not
we're in milwaukee tonight right
otherwise it would have been right you
could ask my wife she'll confirm this
about 90 of my wardrobe is carhartt you
know it's it's rural rugged blue-collar
people working-class people who are by
and large anti-vaccine mandates so it's
total it's an example of total tone
deafness from a corporation about their
core target demographic and that is a
real problem and it's a problem for us
too because we can't just boycott
everything right there you know what am
i going to do i'm going to take all my
carhartt clothes now and you know burn
them in the fire pit like
naked right it's like you know i love my
car art stuff and it's it's it really
breaks my heart that they're doing this
but um you know at the same time it's
almost like where are the options right
you know where's the non-wool company uh
out there and it's like it's almost like
everywhere you turn it's it's every
single corporation you cannot escape it
strangely starbucks check this out from
people drops covet vaccine and testing
requirements for employees after a
supreme court ruling
out so so i live in west virginia not
too far away from where we do this
production and uh i went to a coffee
shop with my girlfriend we wanted to go
shop local and so we went to this local
shop with a big sign in the door saying
you had to wear a mask and i look behind
me and it's like 100 feet away it's
longer than it's across the street and
i'm like there's a starbucks right there
they have no mass mandate let's go there
and stop i'm gonna go there right i'm
gonna go there um i would rather give
money to the small business but not if
you're in west virginia of all places
supposed to have all this freedom and
you as a private business want me to do
that i'm not gonna cry about it i'm not
gonna go you you crazy i'm gonna be like
oh well starbucks it is i guess i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna complain to the
store but i'll tell you this after this
i'm gonna go first thing in the morning
i'm gonna buy a bunch of starbucks for
the whole staff i don't i don't like the
company to be completely that's the psy
up dude don't fall for it they make us
all angry and villainous and that's a
trust person to the first person to
relax is the kingdom of britain the king
the queen and the corporations of
starbucks they want you to start
because they wanted to re-educate all of
their employees on specific uh sjw kind
of principles yes and in that instance i
would be like okay i'm not gonna shop
there but when someone does something
right i want to encourage it if
starbucks is saying we're dropping this
i want to go there and say you guys are
awesome i love what you're doing let me
buy some coffee from you do more like
this let starbucks realize that when
they do that woke insanity lose
customers and when they when they do
write by working-class people they gain
customers i talk about this all the time
the the most power that we have is our
wallet where we're spending our time and
where we're spending our money that has
the most that is how you vote right that
is the best way to vote and that is what
gets the most action from these
companies is when they see their their
profits go up after making a move like
this they're going to pay attention to
that if starbucks ends up making a bunch
of money retaining employees and is
starbuck starbucks publicly traded it is
right yes if their stock value goes up
it's not just the company it's the
shareholders and they're gonna be like
tell starbucks to do more like this
we're making money it's improving my my
portfolio is doing better and then
starbucks gonna be like hey the
customers have spoken
that's why you reward companies and they
do right you punish them when they do
bad and if the people that have stock
and starbucks have a lot of stock in
starbucks and they're like hey we like
that this company is making us money now
we want all our other investments to
start doing what they're doing exactly
well the principles here matter carhart
has about 5 500 employees starbucks has
over 200 000 but the people working at
carhartt now have to make a very tough
decision you know especially if they
can't get this procedure especially if
they have some complications or if they
just personally have religious values or
belief systems that that complicates
this they have to choose their
livelihood over complying with the whims
of a corporation that's not even liable
for a product that they're forcing them
to take that's disgusting orwellian
behavior that should never be tolerated
and they are facing a lot of backlash
they are facing a lot of boycott and and
good um
i think maybe they were trying to double
down on their yuppie hipsters because it
is blue blue-collar people who do wear
uh their clothes but it's also a lot of
urban hipsters uh as well maybe they're
just trying to appease their they're
kind of
trying to reshift their brand just to be
cool i don't know they didn't have to do
anything yeah that's the point
starbucks doing this
is them
deciding to to make a public
announcement that they had to if they
didn't want to have the mandate they
could have dropped it and said okay
we're not gonna you know they they
they're dropping it they're making that
statement
car art or starbucks it could have said
nothing they could have just been like
uh
we'll just do nothing and change nothing
starbucks has had to make that shift
carhartt decided to reinforce and
announce to everybody we're gonna we're
gonna keep doing this so
there it is you know the carhartt has
made their decision at a time when most
of these companies know there's a major
divide in the market
why carhartt
this is the crazy thing to me starbucks
is the woke company and they chose
freedom and carhartt is the
working-class company and they chose
oppression
totally upside down totally upside down
and you know i think this is a perfect
example of of the parallel societies
that we're seeing right they're seeing
two different societies here and two
different sides of the narrative and two
different shifts in what companies are
going to do they're gonna have to start
making choices like this every day and
it's going to impact their bottom line
and people need to again vote with their
their dollars that is the most important
thing your time your dollars that is
where you have the power we actually i
made this joke the other night but we
have a vaccine mended on this show
everybody who watches has to be
vaccinated oh yeah so if you're at home
and you're not vaccinated i'm just
kidding
are you thinking about lifting the
mandates i've officially lifted all the
mandates if you're watching at home and
you are not vaccinated and you are not
wearing a mask we're going to allow it
because we're we're right there we're
right there with starbucks that's right
starbucks we're going to make a lot of
new hires this year were those of their
worst one were those of you listening at
home not wearing a mask
oh my gosh yeah yeah yeah we'd have to
spend two or three years a bunch of
money and investigation to get to the
bottom of this yeah
i'm just pretending like we're the
american government wasting time oh
right everybody send us 20 million
dollars and we'll investigate ourselves
this january 6 committee it feels like a
lot of money and a lot of attention on
something that is not that big of a deal
maybe yes like what an amount of
attention and money has been spent on
this one day
relatively non-violent it's like the
monica lewinsky bill clinton scandal in
my opinion i can't say it was relatively
not someone did die some people died so
definitely
but it wasn't like on there no no the uh
the storming of the storming the
entrance into the capitol one woman died
because she was killed back up yeah
right and then i think somebody fell off
the wall and then someone was trampled
someone had a heart attack so cops were
cool let me tell you why they have to
keep this narrative alive they are
trying to demonize 80 million people in
this country that is why they are trying
to keep this narrative alive full stop
you know we all know common sense people
know i think both on the left to right
really wasn't that big of a deal okay
not the biggest not the the deal that
they're making it out to be
they're going to keep dragging this on
and milking this cow for as long as they
can for the purpose of demonizing 80
million people in this country that is
what is it it's about but you guys want
to know something
you know
when we did a poll of uh our show and
people who watches it was mostly like
moderate libertarian-leaning individuals
they weren't far right or left or
anything just regular kind of people and
then you have a it leans a little bit
more right in some areas than it would
left but we actually had people who
self-identified as socialist and far
left who watch the show some people hate
watch it some people actually like
watching it but um beyond this show
which is
i guess it's a big show
but joe rogan's a really big show
when you have joe rogan
praising james o'keefe and i was that
was that was incredible awesome uh and
joe actually defended me i'm eternally
grateful joe that was i really do
appreciate it he was talking with james
lindsey
joe's a regular guy who leans left i
mean he's pro-ubi
the the regular people in this country
aren't falling for any of the stuff
anymore the establishment can come out
and scream january 6 or whatever they
want but regular people are just like yo
we don't believe you you've lost we're
not with you anymore your narrative is
gone cnn's ratings are 90 down msnbc 90
down people aren't buying you know what
makes me nervous did you see that video
of the kids uh i don't know what country
it was in but they were asking the kids
do you i was france i think you wanted
oh yeah yeah these little six-year-olds
and what do you do if someone's not
vaccinated you call the police take away
everything from them until they comply
so it was one of the response by the
little girls who was speaking in french
there has been a de-escalation away from
authority in society but then the re
kind of brainwashing of children is
happening now that i haven't seen a lot
of but that that video was crazy their
biggest fear is us waking up and stop
the bickering between democrat and
republican left and right and uniting
together against the regime that is
their biggest fear that is why they keep
pumping all these stories on both fox
and cnn constantly with the drama what
did aoc wear on her dress what did she
tweet today all this nonsense to keep us
distracted and divide it and focused on
batting heads with one another instead
of uniting and batting head again
against the the dragon right what do you
think would happen if in 2015 or like as
we're getting in the 2016 cycle bernie
and trump teamed up
that was so awesome because
because the the insurgent populist left
which very much does not get along with
the insurgent populist right but both
despise the establishment the regime the
cathedral
it would have been it that would have
been a a that would have been a
political revolution in this country but
they effectively made sure that you know
bernie he caved he gave right into the
machine and he changed his positions
bernie was the was open bernie said open
borders is a bad thing
for you three four years later he's like
it's a good thing if bernie stuck to his
his positions and actually worked with
with the right and the right was willing
to work with him the establishment would
have been would have been wiped out but
they're holding on by a thread with this
biden guy who can't think straight and
it's and it's sad it is thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 00 pm and
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you